good to have reg back reg how are we I'm
doing well Theodor so is the joe flacco
era mover in Baltimore is that the
writing on the wall is it all about
Lamar Jackson now oh I think it's a
little too early to turn the keys over
to him but I I think I think they're
making another set of keys let's put it
that way so well let me ask you a
question don't you think if this is
going to be the Lamar Jackson coming out
they should do it now because don't you
wish
Kansas City kind of would have done this
with Patrick mahomes last year well even
though they had Alex Smith don't you
think what we're seeing now from Patrick
Mahone's and this starts at the Kansas
City has had even though it was a tough
loss last night don't you wish you
probably got more reps last year as
opposed to just like a lot because a lot
of people assume he's a rookie he's not
oh yeah yeah I think he was more ready
for this than Lamar Jackson is given the
style of offense that he had in the the
big 12 I think he's a better passer I
think Lamar Jackson is a better athlete
so I I think Lamar needs a little more
time and playing against the Raiders
let's see how he plays because you're
not gonna run 27 times and I think if
you can get him where it's a little bit
more equal in you know the number of
passes he throws I think that that would
be a big step in progress for him cuz I
don't know how he is as far as reading
defenses and you know a lot of times you
look at your first option your first
read and then you go nope not there and
then he'd take off and that's not that
that's not how you play the position so
that that's what I would be concerned
about with him fair enough
okay did you watch the game last night I
did fantastic game and it's interesting
because look both teams not even one
coming in to Monday Night Football both
have young I would say young superstars
at the quarterback position and but you
know we still don't know nine and one
it's a great start both well I assume
we'll go deep in the playoffs but being
on Monday Night Football
the only game all eyes on you and both
quarterbacks did not disappoint are they
are either teams to be a front-runner to
win it all
you can't give up 54 and 51 points and
be your frontrunner right you just can't
you've got to play both sides of the
ball your defense has to show up and as
well as the Rams have been and you know
I love girly and I love golf but you
can't give up 51 points at home at home
and be a front-runner you've got to win
I get it you're ten and one but they
don't jump to the head of the line now
because of that victory last night but
Patrick Mahone's is the truth he's real
it's just disappointing how their
defense is I mean you put up 51 points
and you can't get a W something's wrong
and that's what people forget about
Golden State when Golden State was
playing well and scoring all those
points they were still one of the better
defensive teams in the NBA
and that gets lost on people you're like
ugh they play like Golden State no
Golden State plays great defense when
everybody's healthy they're they're very
very got good on ball defenders and
you've got guys who play the passing
lanes really well so there is a big
difference there and let me say this for
everyone who thinks the sky is falling
up in San Francisco stop it and I
understand Steve Kerr's words saying the
deep explain you know a fantasy game and
this is the real NBA win hole win
healthy and I will say this as someone
of a shot went on the same page because
right now they're not on the same page
no one can touch this team and Curry's
been out three months had a toe injury
and they're not right and that is
showing it shows and I said the one
thing that could derail a three-peat
would be injuries but we're not even a
third into the season people so relax
they've lost what 4 out of 5 3 out of 4
but are we really going to judge this
team in November or are we gonna wait
until April to see how they're playing
who cares where they finished one two or
three you're not going to be able to
beat them in hole when healthy and on
the same page in a seven-game series
and if I'm Steve Kerr and I'm that
ownership group I do have to get Kevin
Durant and I do have to get dream
arguing in the room and we've got to
talk this out because we got to nip this
in the bud now because things like this
can fester a little bit but you can't
hang them together can you reg you can't
keep this this team with that salary
together someone's gonna have to take
less and rather the clay or dream on
dream on is not a back player he didn't
see the max player he's sadly mistaken
but the most important person for this
team for them to keep him as a max
player is Kevin Durant and I think that
was probably indicated by the actions by
the Warriors in suspending dream on that
one game look we've all heard what Ben
said what was that in that huddle about
we don't need you to win a championship
dream on I love you and I would always
love to play with you but you are dead
wrong my friend because you do not went
back to that championship is it for
Kevin Durant I'm sorry you're great but
you guys need Kevin Durant and Steph
Curry and yourself in clay to win it all
why would you want to stay if you're
Kevin Durant the road to the final is
easy I'm playing with great Hall of Fame
players and if they go on to win a
three-peat how can you walk away from a
three-peat with a chance to win four in
a row you they win a championship the
only way Kevin Durant is leaving is if
they don't win the championship this
year they win the championship he's not
going anywhere they'll find a way to
sign clay and dream on but you don't
walk away from champions yeah I see I
think he walks away if they win the
championship I think he walks away
either way to go where I think New York
New York or the or the Lakers but I
still go back to I don't know if Durant
wants to help LeBrons legacy and and
give him another title or two you know
if that's the case if that's the case
your words why not stay in gold state it
makes sure he never gets there ever
again but I think he doesn't like being
called the villain the guy who ruined
basketball he's got draymond Green
chirping in his ear and it's November
like you know I think he's a very
sensitive guy maybe too sensitive for
the you know the platform pedestal that
he's on did I certainly wouldn't go to
New York there's gonna be Hyder right no
they can't be they can't be that high I
mean they can't be any lower than they
are so you can go in there making the
playoffs in New York is gonna be good
for Kevin Durant after Woody whole maybe
three championships in a row and being
as we speak a two times Finals MVP you
in a third championship you stay right
there and it's tickets who cares what
people say on Twitter and that he does
well he should dude is a two-time Finals
MVP and back-to-back championships and
has a chance to to be a part of a
three-peat
who gives a rat what people are saying
do you I think that he does midnight
that's why I think that he he will
anyone should get paid he is it you're
right and he will if he he will he will
get paid and he is a sensitive superstar
who doesn't like bad press but guess
what Katie we've all had bad things said
about us you see you were look dude you
got two rings man then what are people
gonna say some people gonna say it was a
chance for a third man look show them
the bird man I wouldn't care what dream
on a saying man Reggie Miller joining us
the Hall of Fame he is right give me the
ball give me the ball in crunch time he
was right to do that oh my god yes he
should have gotten the ball and they
would have had a chance to win and dream
on shouldn't have been the one that had
the ball at the very end absolutely so
we're talking to Reggie Miller reg has
the call for the kings and the Clippers
November 29th at 10:30 Eastern on TNT
best team in Los Angeles is
still the Lakers with honorable mention
to you feel it no justice Clippers have
won five in a row yeah they have they've
been a surprise and his sweet Lou
Williams does not make the all-star team
this year somewhat wrong he should've
made it last year Doc Rivers with the
band of misfits he has these guys play
hard they played together and they've
got that one closer they've got that guy
that they can count on in the crud in
Lou Williams so right now I'm still
going to say the Lakers with the best
player in LA in LeBron James
but it's the Clippers are not far off
Theodore they're not far off why is it
LeBron can go for a three at the end of
a game against Miami to get what 53 or
whatever it was or make sure he got 50
but Devin Booker gets criticized when he
tries to go for 50 against the Celtics
didn't like it I love LeBron but I
didn't like that okay basketball guy you
don't mess with the basketball gods and
LeBron of all people should kind of know
that because I think Luke wanted to pull
him from that game and he told Luke I'm
going for 50 and LeBron on that team
especially the Lakers this year will
have plenty of opportunities to go for
50-plus because he doesn't have a lot of
help I just don't like messing with the
basketball gods and doing that because
they come back to bite you at some point
in time but he got his 50 and that's
great but Theodore you know me I'm old
school and Josh Richardson was right to
kind of react the way he did I just
think he were showing them up a team a
franchise that you want to championships
with I personally just did not like it
I'm curious what you think of what
Junior Smith said about the Cavaliers
he's not buying that the Cavs are you
know trying to make the playoffs or have
any interest in making the playoffs they
they fell to 2 and 13 Junior Smith told
the athletic I don't think the goal is
too
and the goal isn't to go out there and
try and to get as many wins as you can I
think the goal is to develop and lose
and get lottery picks I think that's
always been the plan the goal is not to
compete to win he said in other words
he's using the T word yes thank you yes
do you think the Cavs are tanking
already I would not purposely say that
Cavs are taking but when you want to
develop young players you're not going
to win very many games and we've seen a
lot of teams do that and get high
lottery picks that's why there should be
in place a reward for everyone who is
not necessarily using the T word and
tanking but if you're going to develop
young players in this league you're
gonna lose a lot of games and I just
think a lot of this too could be
frustration on juniors part that he's
not a part of this youth movement what
she shouldn't be and they should find
ways to move him to a contender and try
to get you know a second round pick back
they don't want to take back salary cuz
I would be thankful he's got a job reg I
mean I'm on true-true
but I think on the right team nothing he
could be a starter for coming off the
bench he could be a reliable 3-point
shooter who would you rather have
Carmelo or junior Smith Carmelo can he
play anymore yeah situation like China I
hope not if you can't play in Houston
where defense is an option I don't know
where you can play though be it alright
does anybody play less defense than
Carmelo just go to the corner and shoot
threes who plays less defense than
Carmelo
um less defense yeah well you had two of
them on the same team Hardin I'm not
gonna say his name Hardin looks like
quite Frazier next to Carmelo what made
it difficult in Houston because you know
you've got Chris Paul who is all about
defense and Tucker who's all about
defense but again it's optional in
Houston and I think that was the
frustration that was coming out in
Carmelo was made to be the skate go
which is not the case one final thing
what's going on with the Wizards with
that backcourt John Wall Bradley Beal
walk you know tells his coach to shut
the bleep up during practice here time
to take the wrecking ball here and uh
maybe start over maybe start tanking
here so you can get Zion Williamson yep
yes I would John Wall Bradley bill to I
think pretty good
not necessarily young point guards but
on the right team especially Bradley
bill but if you're John Wall and you
consider yourself in the lead point
guard and you led to death go for
50-plus through 3 and then Dane loom or
Dame Damian Lillard comes in your joint
it gives you 40 can't call yourself an
elite point guard you can't let your
your your peers go off on you like that
and consider yourself an elite and then
you go off on your your coach like that
Scott Brooks time for a fire selling in
Washington it is how about my boy Kemba
Walker going for 60 and then going for
43 Kim was on fire
I just wish and you know it's funny is
he's been doing this maybe not to the
extent of 60 and 43 but he's been in the
elite point guard for some time now he's
just been on a bad team at Charlotte
he's averaging 29 I know
I just you know nobody gets to see him
he's gonna have one of those careers
unless he gets traded where you know we
look at it and go oh that's right he put
up some really good numbers man mm-hmm
he brings it every night he plays hard
in plays hard every night love watching
him play no matter no matter the
situation the team and I think a lot of
that has to do with maybe the ownership
group that's there and obviously Air
Jordan he plays one way every single
night and you're right because it's
Charlotte not a lot of eyes are on the
Hornets and but the way he's playing and
the way he's approach to this season
he's brought a lot of attention to the
Hornets how's the family
the family is doing well I just want
everyone to know I have to thank you
seed or thank you so much for your kind
words to my family you know right after
the Flyers and stuff obviously we had to
leave Malibu and we ran into you at the
hotel and you could not be even more
nicer to mama bear by two kids so thank
you and we were one the lucky ones so
don't worry about the Millers we are
fine I'm all focused on a lot of the
families that lost everything and to me
that's much more important you know
there's a lot of people that have zero
place to go and we'll be fine my efforts
are focused on the people in Malibu
don't that don't have anything so my
hearts go out to them the brave firemen
who you know they battle this thing for
you know over a week that's where the
real heroes lie so I appreciate your
words to my family and the den hats I
cannot thank you enough Theodore you
were really gracious so thank you and
that video you showed me where you could
see where the fire went right up to your
back porch I mean yeah I mean yeah
you're you're fortunate that you know
your wife got the the two kids out and
you know not everybody can say that but
just the devastation I saw just in that
video was incredible yeah we again lucky
but there's other people that lost
everything
that's much more important as helping
them out in their relief efforts there's
a lot of kids and my son's pre-k that I
lost everything so we are trying to help
them out that it's much more important
especially around this time of
Thanksgiving and the holiday season
coming up we need to extend our hands
out and help people as opposed to
looking in the mirror and saying why be
let's let's help other people out as
opposed to focusing in on yourself Happy
Thanksgiving as happy as it can be reg
we appreciate you joining us and we'll
talk to you soon I appreciate a Theodore
Dan yet we love Thank You Reggie
that's Reggie Allah wishes Miller jr.
the third so I'm out at the pool I'm
sitting there and I see these two little
kids and I see a woman who's with him
and I look over and I see what turns out
to be Reggie's son and he's just like
Reggie like he just a and he's got the
this blondish brown curly hair and he's
just kind of animated and I said Reggie
I wasn't sure if that was your wife and
kids cuz then his wife called and said
Dan's down here she didn't go up to me
cuz she didn't want to bother me reg
comes down I said I looked and saw that
you know that had to be your son and
just then he's doing he's animated
dancing around the table and I said yep
that that's you red right there
four more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]